[Music]
there is a weight a man can accrue
this is where all the good stuff happens
the weight created by his past actions
it is a weight which can never be
removed
all in
you count cards right i'm not that smart
bet you win
you need someone to stay cute that's
what you do you run a stable
i'm always looking for a good
thoroughbred
having been sentenced to 10 years in
prison i learned to count cards
how'd you do that
[Music]
poker is all about waiting check raise
re-raise call then something happens
you remember him
this is where all the good stuff happens
they made you the fall guy you need to
back off
you've been around him he's a mystery
and i don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing
this is how it starts just the fleeting
thought
you might want a piece of what i'm gonna
do then it builds
what is that set thing straight
it doesn't matter to me if you did
something bad in your past
nothing nothing can justify what we did
we are each responsible for our own
actions
you know the phrase tilt just like a
pinball
any man can tilt you can tilt
is it possible to know
when one reaches the limit
[Music]
you have to be the strangest poker
player i ever met oh you have no idea
[Music]
[Music]